I was playing a slot and I was looking
at one of these little piggies and I was
like smiling at me I love those little
[__] imagine when they can put a
little AI into these things so when you
walk up and you put in your players card
and the pig can smile at you and go
welcome back Cody oh you're like oh my
God hey Piggy hi piggy Day pal hi hi
Cody nice to see you again are you back
together one of us again you're like
yeah I am fill me up Cody it'd be so
funny if they sort of like roasting you
a little bit too yeah ah come on you got
more money than that you were here for
eight [__] hours yesterday yeah they
can all just talk to you they have
personality I can't wait for that dude
that's definitely gonna happen yeah